let's go girls Man I Feel Like a Woman
how about an icon and when a door slams
in your face take a freaking run just
run and leap at that door
and
kick it down honored with the music icon
award Shania shuts it down at the
People's Choice Awards okay so you're
right man
it's not every day you get shouted out
by an icon right Ryan taking to
Instagram Ryan reveals this may be the
best thing that's ever happened to me
and basically the Canadian star is
exactly like us while watching Shania
perform it proved to be a massive night
for Ryan who also took home people's
icon award Blake and My Girls you are
quite literally you're my heart you're
my hope you're my happiness
could I be a backup singer for Adele
maybe I couldn't be her but I could
maybe do the backup singing
feeling we should have had it oh
back inside Kathy Hilton proves that
lipstick is uh always a must I um
I just want to celebrate yeah there's
Kathy doing a on stage touch up while
Law and Order star Mariska Hargitay
accepts her award also accepting an
award Kelly Clarkson who is out on a
date with her daughter this is awesome
I'm having a date night with my daughter
River Rose
ice cream and my baby girl
and while Chloe may arrive a little bit
late to accept the best reality show
award you know it'll be collected in
style where were you I was trying to fix
my hair oh my God
all right